start with me stuffy  okay Vega you cannot enter this  tournament with razor sharp blades  strapped your hand I can't even believe  I have to say that but they're stabbing  at how I fight I stab I fight I stab I  find I am also sexually open would you  like to taste sorry I don't know ever  stop kissing why stop kissing a mask  make you feel uncomfortable tell me Dad  when you kiss a woman do you look so one  side is sharpened once dull for licking  hey how else may look a clown or can I  ask you a personal question what does  that sound you make when you do your  special news what what what yeah that  sounds like Julia Child experimenting an  ass play my god what a painful image you  look like I paid $50 to watch you in  Vegas $50 that's quite a ticket price  think about it think about it it's a no  you can't use the claw you can't use  them in  like a